it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day
for that we turn to fox news contributor
raymond arroyo raymond great to see you
there were a couple of travel stories
that have caught your eye yeah pete you
know from your extensive travel it's
hell out there i had two trips delayed
or canceled by as many as 13 hours in
one case i missed two shows on this
network a while ago i developed
raymond's rules for air travel which
included do not clip your toenails while
on board aircraft you can take an eye
out and arm rests are to keep you in
your seat so abide the divide i hate
spillage well i'm adding a few new rules
okay owing to a story that just landed
pete on a recent southwest flight
passengers started air dropping via
their apple phones nude pictures to the
pilot he took to the intercom
so here's the deal this continues while
we're on the ground i'm gonna have to
pull back to the gate
everybody's gonna have to get off we're
gonna have to get security involved
and it's vacation that's gonna be ruined
so you folks whatever that aircraft
thing is quit sending pictures let's get
yourself to combo
which brings me to my new rule pete do
not send porn to the pilot leave him
alone
it's true that sounded like dad in the
front seat like kids i will turn this
plane around if you do not behave back
there and they're going to cabo so if
they want to send i mean they're halfway
there just wait you know you got the
camera just give it time right
give it time
uh raymond where were any of your uh
delays because lost baggage has been an
issue for some people i know too is that
part of it you bet
you know that was not the reason for my
delays but it does bring me to another
rule do not check baggage on certain
airlines according to the department of
transportation the worst airlines for
mishandling baggage meaning losing
damaging or stealing your bags since the
top of the year were american which
mishandled 450 000 bags pete followed by
alaska airlines and jet blue just stuff
the carry-ons just fill them up and
don't look back but don't check anything
they don't really check them at security
anymore if they're too big you know you
used to have to put them in those things
and make sure they're the right size
they don't really check that so if you
get it to the gate you get a gate check
it stays with you okay don't tell them
pete don't tell everybody they're going
to take all of our overheads
that is actually the way to go right now
you're right i have how they have not
figured out scanning of the bags and
putting on a plane quite yet i don't get
it but we'll get to we'll get to another
topic appreciate these tips it's
actually helpful joe biden uh gave an
angry speech you saw it riddled with
flubs yesterday watch
keep guns out you know what the mexicans
are
mexico which has real problems causing
us real problems you know what their
biggest complaint is
can't we stop
gun trafficking across the southern
border into mexico we can solve more gun
crimes if we have
the
someone heading up which we finally do
we the people
that's how our constitution starts the
declaration we the people
pete he isn't sure where he is anymore i
mean today jill biden dr biden was
holding a white house meeting on
strengthening teaching urging more money
for public school teachers which you
recently wrote about and we know how
much good that does then the president
wandered in pete
and these partnerships uh will continue
to exist i'm going to start talking
right now
and i'm done
speaking of partners
[Laughter]
that's a wrap
i don't know what they're all laughing
about the poor man wanders in he mutters
whatever she says i agree with and then
he left but this is the problem pete
because increasingly we see a president
he's being led around at times literally
by the wife and the staff and you just
don't get the sense that he's in charge
of any of this
no and he wouldn't be aware of the fact
that by saying that he's reinforcing the
already preconceived notion that other
people are handling things whatever she
says what we're gonna do how many times
a day does is does he say that in
response to what good thing the easter
bunny was in the hall to pull him out
pete that was
good good save easter bunny yeah you see
the furry hand ripping through it's true
now back in your hometown of new orleans
there is an effort to recall
mayor latoya cantrell what's driving it
well principally her lavish spending and
skyrocketing crime we have an 83 percent
increase in murder since 2019. but now
the mayor's office is responding her
campaign manager claims the recall
effort to undermine and discredit the
first black woman mayor of new orleans
fits into a long history of taking away
our vote and our voice that's why we
have reason to believe a conservative
d.c firm has signed on to lead the
effort that's why many gop organizations
in the city are encouraging people to
sign the petition that's why fox news is
leading the propaganda charge now pete
it's you fox news merely reported this
once it was announced secondly the two
people who filed this recall effort
against cantrell are democrats one of
them
eileen carter actually worked for
cantrell she tweeted today why are you
lying about your residence and to your
residence sad belden the other fellow
who signed the recall effort and i are
both black and this is not a race issue
it's a job performance issue so again
you see this kind of um
double talk and and and the
administration trying to cover its
tracks but these are black democrats
leading this recall effort because of
the crime principally the crime you know
that you know that city better than
anybody i know is there a real
grassroots feeling that it's out of
control and she needs to go absolutely
all over the city in lakeview uptown all
over black white and in between uh
there's a revulsion against what the
mayor the state she's created in the
city
they always
someone always ends up crying racism and
that's not what it's about stand strong
hopefully that city deserves a lot
better hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else